today marks the start of a major test
for vaccine mandates all around the
country while New York City's mandate
for teachers to be vaccinated was put on
hold by a federal judge the Mandate for
the state's health care workers is going
into effect those workers must now have
at least one dose and that's leading to
fears of Staffing shortages an estimated
72 thousand Hospital workers are not yet
fully vaccinated Statewide and that's
about 16 percent of the workforce we're
joined Now by Dr Ashish jaw he's dean of
Brown University School of Public Health
good morning to you Dr John it's always
good to see you
foreign
good morning thanks for having me back
okay let's start with the vaccine
hesitancy among the medical workers
because if I was a non-vaccinated person
and I see health care workers are not
getting vaccinated I would think do they
know something that I don't how do you
explain the vaccine hesitant hesitancy
among that group of people
yeah so the way I remind people is that
97 maybe 98 of all doctors are
vaccinated uh 80 90 of nurses are
vaccinated so there really isn't a lot
of hesitancy it's a very small group
they're very noisy they're very loud and
they make it look like lots of
healthcare workers are hesitant but they
really aren't most health care workers
have gotten the shot already
okay that's really good to know because
you're right they're very loud and
they're very noisy and they get a lot of
attention now here in New York there is
a plan possibly to call in National
Guard health workers to fill in for some
of the shortages what do you think of
that and have you ever heard of such a
thing
yeah the shortages are being caused by
the fact that we've had this massive
surge in the South and so what that has
actually meant is pulled nurses away
from New England New York Mid-Atlantic
midwest states to the South that is
really causing a major part of the
problem I don't think vaccine mandates
are the source of the shortage but it is
unprecedented to have uh you know
National Guard coming in to help but
this is the crisis we're in and as long
as the infection continues to rage in
many places in the country we're going
to need stop Gap measures like this
I don't know can we talk about the Dr
wishawinski's decision where she went
against her board we talked about it
briefly last week and she's still
defending her decision what do you make
of the difference between the two
yeah I actually thought she made the
right call and I didn't think it was
actually a close call you know the
advisory committee and it's just an
advisory committee uh said that they did
not see evidence that high-risk health
care workers uh people who are on the
front lines needed to get a booster yet
I disagree I don't I see the data as
showing that they do and Dr wolinski
clearly reads the data in the same way
and this is her prerogative she is the
appointed head of the CDC so I thought
she made the right decision but then
again you then have the problem again of
the mixed messages and I think the last
thing people need to have not been
vaccinated is to get mixed messages
I totally agree Gail I mean look this
the messaging on this has not been as
clear as it should be here's the way I
would think about it first of all
absolutely essential right now that
people get their first shots if you've
not been vaccinated my goodness you've
got to go out and get vaccinated if you
are six months out from your second shot
and you're in any kind of a high risk
group or a high risk profession the
evidence is coming in that you probably
should get a booster and that's
basically the message that we should be
saying get the first shot if you haven't
get a booster if you're in a high-risk
situation I I think that's where the
evidence is
I can't wait to get the booster I will
try not to trample little children on
the way to get get in line thank you
very much
yeah thank you I won't I promise thank
you sir for your time